if it wasn't for Jackie Chan then in all
likelihood the bio near would not exist
as a child I was absolutely obsessed
with Jackie Chan I bought all of his
DVDs and I just sit there
fast-forwarding to the fight scenes and
watching those the way he moved in his
physicality was incredible to me he
seemed like a real-life superhero Jackie
Chan inspired me to start martial arts
karate at the time along with Shenmue he
also encouraged him to start working out
I'd go on walks with my sister and do
stunts and get to film in general he was
just a massive part of my childhood he
moved so fluidly and later on when I
watched the documentary jump London with
sebastien foucan
one of the inventors of parkour I was
actually really annoyed to see him
credit Bruce Lee as his main source of
inspiration and give no lip surface to
Jackie Chan this is just one part of his
overall package Jackie Chan embodies
everything that his site is about so
what is a secret what we learned from
Jackie Chan's life in his training in
this video I'll attempt to break it all
down I'll be referring to several books
including his autobiography as well as a
book by John Whipple who also gave us
many collections on Bruce Lee and
countless endless extra materials from
DVDs
so Jackie Chan was born in 1954 as Chan
Khong sang and it wasn't until much
later when he was working as a
construction worker that he would adopt
the nickname Jackie Chan as his now
legend Jackie Chan's training began very
early when he was just six years old and
he was inducted into the China drama
Academy as part of the Peking Opera his
Hollywood legend now that his parents
were so poorly off to sell him at first
and this was one of the only ways they
could afford to keep him peeking operas
a flamboyant and majestic art form that
involves singing acrobatics martial arts
and incredibly colorful makeup and
costumes
it requires extreme precision and
perfection from his artists and the
China drama Academy had a rather
rigorous way of extracting it when
Jackie Chan's father gave him over to
the Academy he had to sign a waiver
saying that they were allowed to
discipline Jackie Chan even to death
it's worth noting at this point that
Jackie had been excited to join the
Academy having visited it a few times
first and he actually was encouraging
his parents to let him join of course
age six he didn't know what he was
letting himself in for that soon became
apparent when he realized just how
rigorous and punishing the regime was
he'd be woken up at 5:00 a.m. every
single morning to participate in a round
of really painful stretching martial
arts acrobatics tumbling they used
corporal punishment as students were
allowed to use the toilet because their
master
you Jim Ewan believed that if they
needed the toilet they weren't training
hard enough that they should sweat it
all out instead students slept on the
wooden floor this is also where they
practice their flips and falls with no
nets no mats they just had to try and
flip and if they landed on their neck
well then they'd learn not to do that
next time
they'd repeat the same kicks and punches
and forms over and over and over
ad nauseam until they were absolutely
perfect there are several videos and
articles on the web claiming that Jackie
Chan isn't a real martial artist that he
doesn't know how to fight and it's true
Jackie Chan doesn't have any experience
in the ring he probably lacks the
mindset to compete in MMA but that by no
means makes him any less of a martial
artist he can deliver a punch or a kick
like the very best of them he could kick
most people's asses he trained this
rigorously 12 hours a day on just five
hours of sleep from this young age
performing splits for hours at a time
at this age you're young your plastic
your impression
there's no way that any of us now can do
anything to achieve the kind of muscle
memory that Jackie Chan has the training
is actually similar in many ways to
Shaolin monk training and you can see
the video I made on that on this channel
furthermore Jackie Chan was actually
considered one of the best at this
Academy he was particularly good at
singing and he was chosen to be a member
of the seven little fortunes a kind of
crack team of their seven best child
performers two more for seven misreport
tunes were you and Bao and also Sammo
hung who would go on to become his
martial arts acting contemporaries
Jackie Chan doesn't hold any grudges
either in fact he's very grateful for
his time there and says that in many
ways Master Yu was the father of Jackie
Chan the martial artist that positivity
gratitude and work ethic is a largely
responsible for how successful he was
subsequent to his time at the Peking
Opera it was common at the time for
pupils from the China drama Academy to
appear in films and Jackie Chan was no
different his first appearance was at
the age of 8 in a film called big and
little Wang tin bar and he'd like to go
on to become a stuntman working
regularly on martial-arts flicks
including fists of fury and Enter the
Dragon opposite Bruce Lee of course
Jackie Chan's first leading roles were
under the direction of lo way and can be
categorized as Bruce rotation you can
check out new Fist of Fury if you want
to see Jackie Chan attempting to emulate
the style of Bruce Lee it's not a
terrible film but it was a flop because
Jackie Chan and Bruce Lee are worlds
apart said you can see some of his
acrobatics and agility already starting
to creep their way in wasn't until
Jackie Chan was on alone under a to
picture deal with seasonal film
corporation that jackie was given a
little bit more creative control under
the direction of the amazing hyun-woo
ping also responsible for the fight
choreography in the matrix and Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon he's a real legend
in the industry here you can really see
Jackie Chan's more rhythmic fighting
style which is a byproducts of his
training as well as more flamboyant use
of props they started fighting with
different objects you can see him using
acrobatics and what really sets the
films apart was the injection of comedy
which was really novel at the time
combined with the kung fu
so the film's snake and Eagle shadow and
the drunken master were huge hits and
from that point onwards Jackie Chan was
given a little bit more creative control
over his future vehicles these films
also features some really rigorous and
inventive training scenes which might
have been somewhat inspired by his time
at the Peking Opera I think my granddad
was also
by this because he got me doing all
sorts of similar training not quite as
grueling but just as inventive and weird
in these films Jackie Chan hangs upside
down from his legs whilst transferring
water from one bucket to another he does
handstand press ups he does push-ups on
his fingers over the top of hot wooden
spikes with his master's legs balancing
on his back there are some
demonstrations of physicality and again
they really set Jackie apart from lesser
imitators in 1983 Jackie Chan teamed up
with un Bao and Sammo hung from the
seven little port toons to create the
project a here you can see his influence
from the silent comedy era including
Harold Lloyd's safety last film in
particular where he actually emulates a
stunt
frame by frame where he drops from a
clock tower this fusion was completely
unique and as such the films were hugely
successful there's no sympathy is not
the best you had to be yourself more
creative and the next evolution in
Jackie Chan's Korea came with Police
Story this was a more modern urban film
seeing director tennis of policemen and
involving lots of shattered glass and a
fight in the mall and a huge stunt at
the end where he slides down a pole
using just his bare hands and crashes
through multiple electric lights
he also chases down a bus man hangs from
it using an umbrella and the rest as
they say is history it's in these films
that we start to see Jackie Chan
performing what could only be described
as a early form of parkour before anyone
was doing parkour he has to flow down
and he says how he would drive past
objects in the real world and then see
opportunities to climb them or fight on
them which is something that today's
trackers described as parkour vision it
wasn't the very first person to do
parkour could be this guy from the 1930s
but he certainly was one of the first
people to popularize this kind of
movement in an urban environment the way
Jackie Chan moves like I say is
completely different from anyone else
and I think that's what really sets him
apart you and Bao is arguably a better
Acrobat is much lighter then you've got
people like Tony Jaa who are probably
better at flips and tricking there's
something about watching Jackie Chan
fight and flip
there's just eminently more watchable
and it's hard to put into words it's
also to do with the way Jackie Chan
moves them this is where you see his
training come in once a
he knows how to add a little flourish to
what would otherwise be a boring hurdle
or vault then there's that sense of
timing and rhythm which is something
that even trained martial artists have a
very hard time getting down some of the
moves he performs I've not seen anyone
emulate like when he jumps through tiny
little gaps I don't know how he does it
as an action hero like this of course
Jackie Chan's training has had to evolve
as well as his Peking Opera training
he's also trained in multiple martial
arts following that he has a black belt
in Hapkido and you can see this in his
more modern film so he has a slightly
more direct style one point Jackie
Chan's physical training involved
45-minute runs every single day but ever
since he injured his ankle filming
rumble in the Bronx he hasn't been able
to run like that anymore so he toned it
down to slightly less rigorous even you
aging involving a Stairmaster he does
train with weights as well on top of
this apparently he benched presses 45
kilograms on either side so if we take
into account the way of the bar then
that's probably just over a hundred
kilograms maybe 110 kilograms and
apparently he'll rep this out with quick
repetitions for 20 or 30 reps he talks
about this in his interview with John
little way also says that he doesn't
train with heavy weights what the hell
whether or not this is completely
accurate Jackie Chan says that he and
his stunt team they're now famous Jackie
Chan stunt team they want to train with
two heavyweights because they don't want
to become massive and bulky they want to
remain light and agile on top of this he
incorporates lots of martial arts
practice of course ripping out huge sets
of punches and kicks and he does lots of
gymnastic standing on his head and
things like that it is this is great for
strength and great for body awareness
and I've extolled the virtues of
incorporating gymnastic style training
into your workouts before but Jackie
Chan also says that most of his
conditioning most of what he needs comes
from his work because he's filming on
the set every single day that means he's
practicing fight choreography that means
he's filming fight choreography it means
that he's throwing himself off of things
he and his stunt team have a huge
repertoire of kind of alphabet of break
Falls and flips and tumbles and then
when a bad guy gets kicks they can just
pick from this index of Falls and find
the one that works for them rake falling
would have an important part of his
training and it's even more important
now it's a big part of what makes him so
resilient and what it's allowed him to
continue his career for so long
interestingly Jackie Chan says it's
actually harder to be the bad guy in the
film because that normally involves
landing on your face which requires a
lot more skill than being the hero and
landing on your feet so as well as
incorporating things like handstands and
planche presses
I also recommend doing more tumbling and
acrobatic styl gymnastics I've recently
incorporated cartwheels into my training
and I highly recommend this as a way of
improving a proprioceptive also building
strengthen your core and just general
agility try and cooperate them into your
training a few days a week and I think
you'll see incredible knock-on benefits
really quickly trust me Jackie Chan
continues doing all of this to this day
to the ripe age of 65 this speaks to
another thing that has in common with a
lot of the other legends I've talked
about in this series Jackie Chan is
fanatically passionate about what he
does and it really comes across along
with his discipline and his optimism
Jackie Chan also has a real zest for
life people have worked with him or
interviewed him talked about how he'll
be constantly working constantly talking
about what he does giving them free
gifts showing them slideshows of his
stunts and his philanthropic work
without them even asking the guy speaks
eight languages and when he's not
writing filming directing or singing
he's probably coming up with ideas for
inventions apparently has lots of things
he wants to patent he was running
multiple businesses always working for a
variety of charities he's used some of
his money to buy himself actual secret
bases with James Bond style secret rooms
because why not he's like a big kid and
in fact his recent book is even cold
never grow up and I love that philosophy
because why should you go out when life
can be that awesome when you're Jackie
Chan said one interviewer anything is
possible
he's like Bruce Lee meets Goku meets
James Cameron meets Tony Stark
his creativity is even on showing the
gadgets he's using in order to improve
the impact of his fight scenes he's
created shoes that padded so he can kick
people in the head without hurting them
and why is that cool people's legs out
from underneath them to improve their
pratfalls this is why I think that
Jackie Chan's use of the role of souped
buggy Roly in the film Chinese zodiac is
perfect it's such a unique invention
such a strange concept and Jackie wears
it racing down mountainsides just shows
how he's much more than a martial artist
he's just completely unique that film
also fYI is one where he holds a world
record for the most number of job roles
on a given production including catering
coordination wheels on meals indeed
there truly is no one like Jackie Chan
so I hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then
thanks a ton for watching check out the
link
in the description down below where you
can see the written post version of this
got lots more like this on the way the
next time I do one of these learning
from legends videos I'd like to look at
a thinker type of person again so let me
know in the comments down below who
you'd like to see subscribe if you want
to see more like this and thanks a ton
for watching this one bye for now